I would like everybody listening
to do the right thing
and advocate for San Francisco to
implement this policy make it happen
what if it works then great it's good
for them why would I be mad because then
they'll do it to your city no no wait
wait what but if it works okay all of a
sudden everyone's holding hands and
singing songs Under rainbows I'd be like
well I'll be damned yeah it worked it'll
be fine problem solved but it's not
going to work it's going to destroy San
Francisco and I'm here for it I'll get
the popcorn San Francisco's already
pretty shredded it's it's an awful place
there's poop everywhere it is look it's
not a good scene if they voted for it
they deserve it the first day I went to
San Francisco I was going to move there
and I parked my car and went to look at
the apartment when I came out my window
was smashed and my bag had been stolen
with my laptop everything lesson learned
Man Dirty city with a lot of desperate
people that's so sad not so so hold on
paying four thousand dollars a month for
a one bedroom kidding me